I've never had an apology and the mets
has wrote a statement that had an
apology in it but no one's ever kind of
phoned or written or said you know this
is terrible and we're so sorry and I
think the reason that they haven't
apologized is perhaps the reason why Sir
Mark won't accept the language
institutional racism
it's about accountability
that's meanest Mormon you might remember
her two daughters Nicole and Bieber were
murdered in a park in Northwest London
in 2020 it later came out that two
metropolitan police officers had taken
selfies with her daughter's bodies then
shared them with a bunch of other
officers on a WhatsApp group
she's speaking to me because yet another
damning report has been published
revealing a toxic culture within the Met
police
the author of the report baroness Casey
found the force to be institutionally
misogynistic racist and homophobic
now Louise Casey started looking into
all this after Sarah everard was
kidnapped raped and murdered by serving
metropolitan police officer
it shocked the country that Wayne
cousins abused his position of trust to
attack and kill a young woman walking
home alone
then when baroness Casey was working on
this report another serving officer from
the same unit David Carrick was arrested
and exposed as a serial rapist there are
at least nine opportunities to stop him
but they were missed so the Bad Apple
Theory no longer sticks
baroness Casey's report now lays bare
that forces failure of women and
children crimes like rape and domestic
violence are inadequately investigated
while a toxic culture allows predatory
behavior to flourish
I'm Sally Lockwood and this is the Sky
News Daily
we'll hear more from Mina in just a
moment first let's talk to our home
editor Jason Farrell he was at the press
conference with Baron SKC when she made
her findings public uh Jason good to
have you with us there's a lot to take
in here what is most striking to you I
think the most striking thing is how
badly the Met is failing women and
children and particularly with rape
investigations and some of the examples
and the detail in this case is really
where it gets really shocking so Luis
Casey talks about the fridges for
example that are used to keep the rape
kits in that's the medical equipment
Police use to collect physical evidence
from rape victims and how sometimes
they're broken or strapped shut or the
doors can't close without two or three
people trying to cram everything inside
and when they break
back in 2022 during my heat wave then
all those tester kits got contaminated
and those cases had to be dropped and I
think if you know if you've spoken to
rape victims I have quite a lot over the
last 18 months or so to think of that
after having given their witness
statements and having to gone through
all of that
invasiveness of the testing and things
like that and then for that
evidence to get lost and the case to be
dropped for that reason is really quite
shocking yeah and Louise Casey said it's
sort of symbolic and I think it is
symbolic and I think that's absolutely
right because the fridge door is
essentially broken on the police force
if you like and the contamination is the
sexism it's the racism it's the
homophobia and she's not saying that
everybody is racist and sex is in the
police far from it she talks about their
professionalism but she talks about this
being you know institutional and and
endemic and part systematic and it's
accepted I think is the problem and the
police force has been too defensive in
the past and she's very conscious of the
fact that have been a number of reviews
that have pointed this out but it's
still there yeah I mean it's extremely
damning to to read the words
institutionally racist misogynistic and
homophobic when talking about the Met
police and of course this isn't the
first time that the Met police has been
found to be institutionally racist they
were also given that damning verdict 24
years ago after the murder of Stephen
Lawrence they were and they don't they
don't particularly like the word
institutional Mark Rowley he's the
current head of the Met he doesn't agree
with it he thinks it's ambiguous it's
political and me you know maybe this is
semantics I I'm not sure I can
understand his
trying to get the message to his fellow
officers that he doesn't think everybody
among them is racist and I think that
that's not what Louise Casey is saying
either
um but I think what she doesn't want is
for them to cherry pick certain aspects
of this report maybe it's more important
that that he does take on the
recommendations than necessarily accept
the language but if you've got within
there a group of people it doesn't have
to be a massive group of people but
enough people who are prepared to turn a
blind eye
where you know there could be a dozen or
so people who know about someone having
a tendency to be misogynistic
and at the very least not discouraging
it then that's a cultural problem yeah
certainly those two instances the first
one with Wayne cousins where he
kidnapped raped and murdered Sarah
everort and then David Carrick you know
arrested and revealed as a serial rapist
those two instances shock the country
but it was the fact that there were red
flags with both of those individuals
there were at least nine opportunities
to stop David Carrick yet neither of
them were rooted out and and that is the
essence of what Louise Casey has been
investigating is is the culture within
the Met as you say that that allowed
these individuals to thrive yeah and it
goes It goes to the kind of core of it
really because it's from the it's from
the worst case scenario which is Wayne
cousins
to you know the really small things and
I think we we have to remind ourselves
that one good thing about this review
is that these are police officers who
are blowing the whistle
part of the thing that they're blowing
the whistle on is the fact that they
don't feel comfortable blowing the
whistle but at least they're talking to
Louise Casey and I can understand why
because she's very forthright she's very
honest and she's good at this kind of
thing the police isn't
we'll speak to Jason more in just a
minute but let's go back to mina
smallman now who you heard earlier in
the episode
Louise Casey went to meet her to hear
firsthand how it felt when she was told
police officers had taken selfies with
her daughter's bodies actually I don't
know how to explain it we were
traumatized anyway and then to have that
I
I didn't have words
and one of the things I said to Louise
was
you know any strides big strides that
we've made
recently has been because of the
tenacity of victims and it shouldn't be
up to the victims to have enough in the
tank to be able to take on a huge
Institution
it shouldn't but you know women who've
been raped domestic violence you know
keep coming forward to tell their
stories and it takes courage to speak
out you know it really does it does it's
not easy to do that and the irony of it
is that the police rely on the community
to Big grasses but they don't allow
people to tell the truth when you found
out that those two metropolitan police
officers had taken selfies at the murder
scene of your two daughters
sort of expert expression as to what
they were doing no I've never had an
apology
they've the mets has wrote a statement
that had an apology in it but no one's
ever kind of phoned or written or said
you know this is terrible and we're so
sorry no nothing and I think that the
reason that they haven't apologized is
perhaps the reason why Sir Mark won't
accept the language institutional racism
it's about accountability this culture
didn't happen overnight it's incremental
so you get away with a bit then you get
away with a bit more and that's where
you end up with this is just the one
group that we knew of 33 in the group 33
in the WhatsApp group yes where the
photo photographs of your daughters were
shared yeah plus two civilians a doctor
and a dentist obviously you've been
through a real ordeal I mean that
doesn't even begin to describe what
you've been through
at what point did you see perhaps you
know the positive version of the
Metropolitan Police because of course
there are also a large number of
officers who are hard-working good
people yeah oh no I we had the full
spectrum we had the shining example of
the Metropolitan Police
that was the team that were
investigating murder I need to share
this story with you because it kind of
sums up for me what is good policing
when the girls were murdered because we
knew they had blankets cushions
all of those things but they weren't
there and so they'd worked out he must
have put it all in a bundle and put it
by the bins now the Rangers in the park
they're very good at cleaning up the
space
so they said you know has there been a
pickup or a collection since and they
said yes
now the rubbish had gone to one of five
tips
and it was the job
of one of the team
David
to go through all the rubbish bags
he did that was it five days or six days
of it now
for those of us who have an imagination
you can just imagine what he had to draw
through
bless him he found it
he found it that is
that is Dedication that is the example
you know that team and how upset were
those officers who who did a really
great job for your family how upset were
they about what happened to you they
were devastated
devastated
you know they they took on and and
that's the truth that the good police
officers will be over compensating now
for the bad ones
you know because if you're honest and
true and you join an organization that
is primarily about people and protecting
people
you care
and so they will be carrying the burden
in addition to an incredibly difficult
job they now will be carrying the burden
for all of these police officers who
have done all of these heinous crimes do
you think the Met police is capable of
Reform now of sorting out these cultural
issues when it comes to sexism
homophobia racism
we haven't got a choice have we what
else is what's the other alternative
well the other alternative is to
dismantle the force altogether which
Louis Casey has said she doesn't think
would be helpful at this stage that
they're better off spending that energy
in in trying to reform what they've got
great and do you think they can
I can't not think they can't you know
everything is worth changing all good
institutions
know that after a time you have to
review
your way of operating
and
make it better you can always make
something better
and
this was a poison chalice you know sir
Mark conversations I've had with him he
you know I've been very Frank
and he's been honest
you know very humble
but today
I think he's he's made a big clanger for
himself because
everything that he said and tried to put
into action
has been brought into question now
because he will not accept the
terminology
of institutional racism and all black
families and people of color
aren't interested in his semantics
this is this is a Eureka moment for him
to say I get it
I get it and I want you to know
that
I understand what you've gone through
that will jar with some people some
people they will not like what I've just
said
tough
you wanted to know what it feels like to
be black now you know
now you know
how do you think the Met goes about
winning the trust of black londoners but
also trying to win the trust now of
London's women yeah it's going to take
hard work
but
just simple things
like people having the appropriate
training for the specific circumstances
you know not all police constabularies
have rape units
and they need it it needs you know this
is a serious crime and the saddest thing
no one really gets it until it happens
to you in your family
it shouldn't be that way you know I'm
not campaigning just for women of color
their safety I'm campaigning for all
women and girls of all colors all
religions because that's what good human
beings do and and so I have to believe I
have to but I I really do think I'm
hoping and praying and I will pray and I
will phone him later and I'm going to
say you know you dropped to clanger
today so you're gonna phone Mark Rowley
later yes what did you want to say to
him I just you know I want to say to him
you have got to know you did you did
yourself no good today
you know I can't defend you I won't
defend you
go away and think about this
I'm you know thinking did someone put
pressure on him
is it that that thing that if you accept
blame
you're guilty of something
but the impact it would make for him to
say yes
we we have institutional racism without
within our uh you know institution and
and we're going to work on that
cost him nothing so
I'm I'm gonna be a good priest and like
a chaplain I'm going to phone him up and
we're going to have a heart to heart
because we're all flawed no one's
perfect so I'm going to walk him through
the reasons why that doesn't work
well look if he doesn't pick up he can
always listen to this podcast yeah Lena
thanks so much for speaking to us thank
you thank you thanks very much
[Music]
okay Jason it certainly feels there's a
long way to go when it comes to
restoring trust with the women of London
and with black londoners as well which
is also identified in this report
what recommendations did baroness Casey
make
yeah we should just mention you know on
black londoners and stop and search and
the fact that a black person is much
more likely
um to be handcuffed to have violence
used against them
um in in a police situation so you know
that is that is a very important part of
of what they're talking about I think
the key recommendation so re reinvesting
in and re-prioritizing Frontline
policing and that's one point was made
is sometimes the closer you get to
public facing police officers the worst
situation is in terms of
um what you know where the way in which
the the police officers are regulated
and and so on on the protection of women
it's actually about having a new
strategy and having dedicated women's
Protection Service and this is
specialist offices too often Louise
Casey says it's someone who doesn't have
that specialism who's dealing with those
kind of things and then I think you know
cleaning itself up by bringing in an
independent team to run the misconduct
system is another really important one
an end-to-end vetting she describes so
you're not just vetted once when you
come in and I think that's quite
important actually because I was talking
to one of the victims of David Carrick
the serial rapist who was also a police
officer
and her point was that if you looked at
his Facebook if you looked at his social
media
you probably could have worked out the
kind of man he was and that kind of
vetting didn't happen whether he was
vetted when he first joined the force is
one thing but this kind of end-to-end
vetting uh that is talked about in this
review I think that's something that a
lot of victims would would follow so
that you know those those are
essentially the tenants the key
recommendations of this report and and I
would say the overriding theme of it is
don't be defensive
you know don't cherry pick from this
this has got to be wholesale you've got
to do this in full otherwise it'll just
be like the responses to all the
previous reports before it won't be
effective and other forces are said to
be under pressure uh too I know this is
something you've been looking into Jason
do you think that this Casey review will
force other forces to look carefully at
their own culture well I've asked I said
to Louise Casey do you think there
should be a Louise case not not how to
do it but should there be a Louise Casey
review everywhere else in every other
Force and and her view is yes there
should be because you to answer your
question I have no idea I think the Met
maybe does have specific problems in
certain areas because it's dealing with
it's a massive force and it's dealing
with all sorts of different issues that
maybe other forces don't face but a lot
of this report might well be applicable
to other forces and as you say they are
now doing an investigation into anyone
with any sort of history of offending
with within the Met police and baroness
Casey has said you know she can't rule
out the possibility that there there
will be other Wayne cousins and David
carricks in the force once they've done
these investigations no and and nor
could anybody
um and that's the thing you know Mark
Riley was asked by Kate Burley about
that and he kind of avoided the question
the the mayor of London was asked the
same question and said he couldn't say
it and then this is the problem no one
can actually yet say and I think Lewis
Casey will only be happy with the
success of her review
if in a year or two years time someone
is able to say yes absolutely and come
back to the point that she was really
conscious that of all the previous
reviews she talked about Hollow promises
about failure to accept the truth about
defensiveness and she just wants more
than anything I could tell from from
listening to her she just wants the
police to take this one on the chin
[Music]
my thanks to Jason Farrell and Mina
smallman and to you for listening to the
Sky News Daily with me Sally Lockwood
this episode was produced by Rosie
Gillett our editor is Philly Beaumont
foreign